- On this the eve of Christmas
I wanted to bring to your
attention the gift of one lawyer,
one Lin Wood, one of the two main lawyers
in charge of all the election lawsuits
along with Sidney Powell.
Mr. Wood filed a verified complaint.
That's a complaint where you swear
that the allegations alleged
therein are true and correct.
It helps you overcome some
of the evidentiary hurdles
that you might face when
you file a complaint
and of course, when you attest
to a verified complaint,
like signing an affidavit,
you swear under penalty of perjury.
Of course in the most
Freudian of slips ever,
Mr. Woods signed under plenty of perjury,
not under penalty of perjury.
That is just the gift that keeps on giving
and if you'd like even more holiday cheer,
check out the video I did
on all the laws broken
in National Lampoon's Christmas Vacation
and I'll see you in court.